So — you went and saw Suspiria.
Maybe you even sat through the whole thing!
This two-and-a-half hour journey is definitely
not the sort of moviegoing experience that
goes down well for everybody.
We're sure you have a few questions.
Around Suspiria's midpoint, Madame Blanc,
the Markos Dance Company's top instructor,
begins to develop a new dance concept centering
around the theme of rebirth.
By then, we're well aware that the company
is secretly a front for an ancient coven of
witches, who seem to be violently sacrificing
young dancers for nefarious reasons.
While the details of Blanc's plan aren't made
totally explicit, her proposal heavily implies
that the dance will be used to resurrect the
coven's ailing leader, the witch called Mother
Markos.
It also seems like the feat will require a
human sacrifice.
It’s implied that the coven tried the ritual
before with the dancer Patricia, played by
Chloe Grace Moretz but something about the
ceremony went wrong, leaving Markos near death
and Patricia's whereabouts unknown.
When audiences first meet Susie Bannion, played
by Dakota Johnson, she evokes a lot of sympathy.
Her sheltered upbringing and self-taught dance
talents serve to make her a protagonist we
can root for, and we spend most of the movie
scared about what's going to happen to her.
The witches of the coven clearly regard her
as a sacrifice in the making, all but licking
their teeth at the idea of offering her up
as part of some deadly ritual.
Of course, by the time we get to the end of
the movie… well, joke's on them, right?
Come to find out, Susie is actually a reborn
ancient witch by the name of Mother Suspiriorum,
one of the oldest witches in existence, who
was central to the founding of the occult
company.
As Susie's staunchly-religious birth mother
later claims while on her death bed, Susie
is not a daughter that she loves, but instead
her greatest sin.
It's a devastatingly mean thing to say about
one's child, but she's also kind of right.
By the end of the movie, Susie is no babe
in the woods, but instead a force of ageless
power who is finally returning to life to
lead a league of witches — even if she's
not entirely aware of her identity when the
movie begins.
While Patricia resisted the coven, Susie embraces
it, going from a newcomer to a leader in the
company with remarkable speed.
But the mystery of what happened to Susie's
predecessor looms over the academy, with Patricia's
disappearance being investigated by fellow
student Sara as the movie revs up toward a
bloody climax.
Minutes before a public dance performance,
Sara discovers that Patricia didn't disappear
from the academy at all.
Instead, she's trapped inside it, somehow
still alive along with other victims of the
witches, including Olga the woman who was
literally torn apart by Susie's dancing.
While the victims are all still alive, their
bodies are rotted and mangled.
Thanks to some witchcraft, they are trapped
in a state of deathless suffering a devastating
fate which soon befalls Sara as well.
The innocent dancers of the Markos company
aren't the only people being manipulated into
involvement in the witches' ritual.
They also target Dr. Jozef Klemperer, Patricia’s
elderly therapist, plotting to bring him into
their rebirth ritual as an unwilling witness.
As we learn throughout the movie, the somber
therapist is haunted by the disappearance
of his wife Anke, who vanished during World
War II.
Klemperer has spent decades trying to move
on from this traumatic separation which makes
it all the more shocking when she appears
to him, seemingly back from the dead, at his
country home outside of Berlin.
In an intriguing twist, she's played by actress
Jessica Harper, who played the role of Suzy
in the original Suspiria.
Their reunion is so emotional that you almost
don't notice that Anke is walking Klemperer
from the countryside back into West Berlin,
right up to the doors of the Markos academy.
As Klemperer realizes where his wife has led
him, she is suddenly revealed to be a cruel
illusion of the witches, leading him into
a trap.
In the movie's final act, the characters all
descend on a hidden chamber inside the academy,
where the rebirthing ritual for Mother Markos
is set to take place.
The company's students are there in a trance,
dancing and forming a sort of human altar
with their bodies.
Klemperer's there among the witches as a captive
witness, and so is the guest of honor Mother
Markos herself, who appears in all her hideous
glory for the first time.
Since her last attempt at reincarnation, Markos
has been described as being on death’s door.
Now we can see why it looks as though she
has become partially fused with another body,
with extra malformed limbs jutting impossibly
from bulbous form.
But soon, it seems, she will be reborn in
a new body Susie's.
As Susie enters the room to begin the ritual,
Markos and her allies believe the time for
reincarnation has finally arrived.
But while Susie is all confidence, Blanc is
uneasy, scared even.
Something feels wrong to her.
Susie isn't acting like the sheltered girl
we thought we knew — she's acting more like
she runs the place, putting Blanc on edge.
Blanc tries to stop the ritual but fails when
Markos attacks her, nearly decapitating her
with telepathic magic, spraying blood everywhere.
With Blanc sidelined, it seems like Markos’
resurrection is imminent.
But it turns out that the ceremony isn't for
her rebirth at all.
Instead, the ritual is the culmination of
a power play from an even stronger witch that’s
been brewing in the background the whole film.
Tearing her flesh open, Susie reveals herself
to be none other than the revived Mother Suspiriorum
— the millennia-old entity who was a founding
member of the witches' occult order.
Susie — or now Suspiriorum — begins to
unleash bloody hell on Markos and her allies
in the coven, who dared to seize power in
her place.
She doesn't do it alone — instead, she summons
the living embodiment of Death itself to stroll
around the room making her enemy's heads explode.
It's pretty trippy.
After Markos and her followers are dispatched,
the rest of the movie is essentially Susie's
victory lap.
She spares the lives of the dancers, as well
as the witches who weren't loyal to Mother
Markos, and also allows Patricia, Sara, and
Olga to finally die, their ruined bodies collapsing
to the ground in an act of motherly mercy.
It's a completely different take on the original
Suspiria's story, and if the movie's cryptic
post-credits scene is to be believed, the
story might just be getting started.
The original Suspiria, directed by Dario Argento
, had two sequels: Inferno and The Mother
of Tears, each focusing on a different one
of the powerful witches known as the Three
Mothers.
Is it possible that the remake director Luca
Guadagnino is explicitly teasing sequels in
the vein of Argento's follow-ups?
While nothing's been announced yet, it is
possible.
But don't worry too much about decoding that
cryptic last shot: according to screenwriter
David Kajganich, the brief scene of Susie
standing in the cold making vague gestures
wasn't even scripted.
Most likely, the scene is just open to interpretation,
meant to send viewers out of the theater thinking,
talking, and weighing the ending's implications,
with a heavy sigh.